hi Richard Partington being the acting
returning officer at the election of a
member of parliament for the rican do
hereby give notice that the number of
votes recorded for each candidate at the
said election is as follows Alan
Dennis Graham UK Independence Party you
Kip 1656 eastern face surely independent
380 Harrison Dylan Labour Party 17,000
887 keys Rodrick Alan Liberal Democrats
1345 McCarthy Patrick Michael John Green
Party 804 Prichard mark Andrew the
Conservative Party candidate 27,400
[Applause]
the number of ballot papers rejected was
as follows want of an official mark zero
voting for voting for more than can more
candidates and voter was entitled to
twenty one writing or mark by which
voter could be identified three being
unmarked or wholly void for uncertainty
ninety one rejected in part zero total
is 115 the electorate was sixty eight
thousand six hundred and four ballot
papers issued forty nine thousand six
hundred and thirty eight the turnout was
seventy two point three five percent and
I do hereby declare that Prichard mark
Andrew is duly elected
[Applause]
well can I thank the acting journey
officer the counting agents and indeed
the police or having conducted such a
professional accounts this evening I
have many people to thank but first of
all I'd like to thank all the other
candidates for having put their names
forward for this election there's a lot
of rough and tumble in general elections
and it's not easy to set aside time from
family and friends but I'm grateful that
you have done that and I look forward to
working with you in whatever capacity as
the Member of Parliament for those that
live within the constituency can I also
thank all of the people of the Rican
who've once again for a record fourth
time have put their trust in me as their
Member of Parliament and endeavour to
return to the House of Commons whatever
the House of Commons looks like tomorrow
morning to work on behalf of all the
people of the Rican whatever their
political complexion whatever their
socio-economic background I'm there to
represent the people of the reeking to
the government whoever the government is
going to be tomorrow rather than the
government to the people I would also
like to thank my campaign team many of
them are here tonight without them I
would not be stood here a cancer Nigel
Nigel doke more cancer and rui actually
jackie Seymour councillor droid Francis
and others council AG Lawrence and many
many others that I can't see or are not
here this evening
councillor Dorothy Roberts and others I
think that you and them for your support
I'd also like to thank my agent Robert
Macy
to the right here who's been
long-suffering agent for me over the
last few elections and again thank you
Robert most of all I'd like to thank
mrs. to muna Pritchard my wife to the
right there for her circle
and it has been a real baptism of fire
some of you won't know I actually got
married on the 13th of May in the middle
of the election and our honeymoon was
rather than the design was actually
given mutual aid in Dudley and and
rather than a Newport Rhode Island it
was Newport Shropshire which was Newport
structures better but anyway there was a
lot going on but I'm grateful that
everybody pulled together not least my
wife giving me support so thank you once
again to the counting agents fabulous
you know it's not how quickly you do it
talking about Sunderland New Castle it's
how well you do it I think we have the
best counting agents in the country
thank you all again god bless you all
Thanks
[Applause]